well we know that these raids are taking
place at the moment at the headquarters
of Paris 2024 in the the Paris suburb of
sandini now it is worth saying it's only
just over a year until the Olympic Games
start in Paris at their sort of like a
later end of July there obviously will
be furrowed by the Paralympics so it is
fairly pressing and awful a lot of uh
effort has already been made to prepare
the city
for this statement event something that
Paris has held before but which is
clearly considered one of the the great
events not just in sport but in the
world and the city is preparing for that
you go to Paris you were already
told information uh about about the
forthcoming Olympics have put a lot of
effort was put into the ticket ballots
that are ongoing and yet within all this
suddenly this announcement not only that
the offices have been raided that
investigators are looking into claims of
Fraud and favoritism but that these also
relate back years that these are a
result of two investigations we
understand one of which actually dates
back to about
2017. so right to the very earliest uh
days when this uh this Olympic bid was
being put together that is to do with
the suspected embezzlement of public
funds and and favoritism uh and uh was
launched by the prosecutor's office the
other investigation much more recent we
understand dates back to 2022 and and
followed on for an audit carried out by
the French
anti-corruption agency so information
coming out all the time office says that
this targets people who are suspected of
a conflict of interest and also of
favoritism in the awarding of contracts
connected to the Olympic games
including contracts reached by the
organizing committee and the company
which is solido who are in charge of
Olympic facilities now it is no great
surprise that over the course of the
Olympics there have always been
controversies that have gone alongside
the carrying out of games and indeed the
preparation for them it's almost a
matter of course but very often these
things these corruption allegations in
the past have surrounded the
international Olympic Committee this is
something rather different this is to do
with the organ committee who are putting
these games together these raids are
continuing they came clearly as a as a
huge surprise as indeed that the police
and prosecutors would have wanted them
to do really we're finding out the
information almost in real time there
was an email was sent around to staff I
understand within the organizing
committee offices up there in sandini
telling them we're being raided at the
moment and you must uh cooperate and I
think this is something that the French
authorities will want to address and
they will want to do it cleanly one of
the reasons you bid for an Olympics were
the enormous multi-billion pound cost uh
price tag that comes alongside it is for
the international Prestige it brings you
right now I imagine that the French
government the French organizing
committee will be feeling rather annoyed
that those offices you are looking there
are not so much the focal point for
Prestige but right now the focal point
for a very different sort of attention